anything you'd like to say Gary
when politics and personality Collide
the future of the BBC's highest paid
presenter is called into question for
being vocal Gary lineker says he stands
by his views have you heard from the BBC
Gary
what does the director General say
anything to you
um yeah oh she said he said well we have
a chat we chat often anything about the
Tweet Gary do you regret sending the
tweet at all no clearly conversations so
far working in lilica's favor with him
remaining on air this weekend but the
row is rumbling on
the Home Secretary has branded his
comments offensive and that they push
the boundaries of freedom of speech to
kind of throw throw out uh those kind of
flippant analogies diminishes it
diminishes the unspeakable tragedy that
millions of people went through working
here in any capacity comes with
guidelines staff are bound by due
impartiality even if they don't work in
news or current affairs the corporation
has a difficult task get rid of one of
the most popular faces on the BBC or
risk making a mockery of those
guidelines one former BBC editorial
director says reaching a compromise will
be difficult I don't think it merits
suspending Gary right now however it
would have to be done his return to
match the day on the basis of the
complaints process was underway and
there would be a resolution to it and
that's why at the moment it's rather
murky what's going on in BBC Salford and
BBC London but there will be all sorts
of machinations going on about how
Saturday works more importantly how the
future conduct of all presenters is
dealt with by the BBC there's Confidence
from one of the corporation's most
popular Stars after this accusation in
the Commons labor are borrowing from the
Gary lineker Playbook they are party of
gold hangers and the occasional
left-wing Striker there was yet more
Defiance I'm just happy to have been
better in the six yard box than you are
at the dispatch box he tweeted
with his spot on the schedule and the
BBC's position unchanged lilica for now
seems Resolute he's going nowhere Ashton
harinag Sky News